[Music]
this is nightmare's collaboration with
fellow good vibrations record label
co-founder slander called fall into me
featuring dylan matthew the dj and
electronic dance music producer has hit
with some of the biggest names in edm
and hip-hop including dylan francis tory
lanez the chainsmokers asap ferg and he
is no stranger to las vegas with a
residency at multiple tell group clubs
as well as hitting the big stage at edc
this weekend welcome tyler moran you
better known as nightmare welcome thank
you i appreciate you having me it's so
great you actually have the day off
today because you have been just doing
everything here in las vegas yes i mean
i'm kind of always on a non-stop
schedule but yeah i got in yesterday
played omni last night and then today is
kind of my
you know doing some press getting out to
see the city a little bit and preparing
the set tonight for friday well edc is
like the super bowl here in las vegas
and you debuted there back in 2015 what
would you tell
2015 nightmare
from 2022 nightmare oh man i don't even
know i mean it's it's kind of surreal
thinking about that first show i played
i was the first person opening the stage
so
as soon as i started playing they opened
this there was literally no one there
and people started trickling in and you
know now i've done a may stage
performance and there was 75 000 people
there so
um
i don't know i don't know what i'd say
to myself just just happy to be here
keep doing what you're doing because
you're doing what you're doing yeah well
you're really your signature is your
stage presence that's what you're really
known for what do you think why do you
think that has really become one of your
signatures
um i mean i think you know particularly
with djing like
the amount of energy that i have is
always
reciprocated back from the audience so
and you know when i've been to shows as
well you know if you're watching and it
seems like the person up there is having
a great time really enjoying themselves
and and you know in love with the music
and what they're doing um it's you know
it's just contagious and so i think
that's you know people can tell you have
such good energy like i just say i can
feel it coming from you how do you how
do you edc fans in vegas differ from
crowds in other cities like edc mexico
or uh in korea i know you've been there
indeed you've been all over the world
how do vegas fans differ um i mean i
think
you know vegas is is one thing and then
edc vegas i think is a whole nother
thing because
it's so notorious around the world
there's so many international fans who i
see here who maybe never have gotten to
see a nightmare show and this is their
first time getting to experience it so
it's cool seeing such a diverse crowd
and such a you know hearing languages
that i you know don't understand and
just people traveling from all over over
the world to to come to vegas to witness
this show so um but the energy is always
the same it's always super high energy
it's something you know i try to keep in
all of my shows now you're going to be
joined on stage by some special guest
can you give us some details on that
well this performance is um a kind of a
collaborative performance with a duo
called big gigantic and they're
incredibly talented musicians they
inspired me when i was first getting
into things and they're from colorado
and so yeah um dom and jeremy are the
two guys dom plays live drums and uh
jeremy or i mean uh jeremy plays live
drums dom will be playing saxophone keys
and occasionally we'll switch up djing
and stuff so it's cool this is a little
bit different more live music mixed with
electronic music kind of combination and
uh we've only done it two other three
other times ever so we're excited sounds
amazing i'm so excited so you have a new
single out which we were listening to
right before the show tell us a little
bit about that um so yeah this one i
wrote with my brother uh one of my
buddies clocks he's just a good friend
of mine we both went to um a music
school in la together um and uh yeah
it's just like a very
happy feel-good kind of energetic song
it's more of an easy listening song
definitely have some some songs of mine
that are not so relaxing and chill and
this is more in that lane so um it's
called the one and uh yeah i'm just just
really excited for that one to be out
when when you say you know relaxing what
do you do to relax i know you played
tennis as a kid do you still do you
still play tennis um i don't i honestly
don't play a ton of sports these days
i'm more into like i'm a hiker i'd
rather you know i go outside and uh you
know
try to hike by myself i feel like that's
kind of my moment of zen do you ever go
up to red rock i have done red rock a
bunch of times i love i love vegas mount
charleston i've done
you know you get the local badge you are
now how do you say nevada that's the
true test
do you say nevada or nevada oh gosh say
nevada nevada yes yeah you're local now
you are it is official thank you so much
for joining us thank you nightmare is
kicking off edc week at liquid tomorrow
and then edc where he will be performing
back to back with fellow dj and producer
big gigantic like we talked about as
gigantic nightmare at midnight at the
cosmic meadow stage
well